- Good evening everyone,
I'm Priya Natarajan.
I'm the current director of the
Franke Program in Science
and the Humanities.
And I'm an astrophysicist by training
and I'm a faculty member at
Yales Departments of Physics
and the Department of Astronomy.
So I am delighted
to welcome you all to this evening's talk
which is part of our
ongoing thematic workshop
and study on the nature of inference,
understanding the nature of inference,
in particular, understanding
causation, correlation,
and understanding these issues
from a multidisciplinary viewpoint.
So as many of you know, we've
had these monthly seminars,
we've had experts, pioneers
who have been working on
using machine learning
and artificial intelligence methodologies
in their particular disciplines,
ranging from chemistry,
biology, computer science,
and physics today.
And I am really happy to
introduce today's speaker
who's part of our core team
for this project as well.
And today's speaker is
Professor Kyle Cranmer,
who is currently at NYU,
but before I give you an
introduction to Kyle and his work,
I want to say a big thank
you to our benefactors,
Richard and Barbara Franke,
who I think are amongst
the audience today.
Their generosity and support
of all the interdisciplinary
activities at Yale,
multifarious activities and
centers that they support,
including the Franke Program
in Science and the Humanities,
has been very, very
impactful in getting scholars
who are otherwise in silos to
actually collaborate, talk,
and interact with each other.
So let me go on now to
tell you a little bit more
about our wonderful speaker.
Kyle is currently a professor
of physics and data science at NYU,
and he's a visiting scientist at Meta.
In July, he will become the director
for the American Family
Insurance Data Science Institute
at the University of Wisconsin, Madison.
It's their brand new effort
in data science at Madison.
He obtained his PhD in physics
from the University of Wisconsin,
so he's going back home, in a way, in 2005
and he got his BA in
mathematics and physics
from Rice University.
He's a recipient of many awards.
I'll just list a few.
He was awarded the
Presidential Early Career Award
for Science and Engineering,
the PECASE, in 2007,
the National Science Foundations
Career Award in 2009,
and he became a fellow of
the American Physical Society
for his work on the Large Hadron Collider.
So one of the key, sort of
the seminal contributions
that Kyle has made is the
development of a framework,
a very robust framework
that enables collaborative
statistical modeling.
And as you can imagine,
with the vast amount of data
from the Large Hadron Collider,
his work was used
extensively for the discovery
of the Higgs boson, which as you all know,
was a major breakthrough
in particle physics
announced in 2012 at CERN.
So his current interests are
at the intersection of physics,
statistics, and machine learning.
And as you can probably guess,
he's one of the pioneers
in our field trying to leverage
these new innovative methods
for obtaining a deeper
understanding of the physical world.
So before I turn it over to him,
let me very quickly remind you
that the format of these talks,
please feel free to put
your questions in the chat.
You have a burning question,
do raise your hand,
something that requires
immediate clarification.
Otherwise we prefer to have
the Q&A session after the talk.
And as you all know,
the format of these talks has been,
we first start out with a colloquium,
and so which Kyle will be giving,
followed by a few days later,
an actual sort of discussion session
in which we have an interlocutor,
another expert in the
field who approaches things
from a slightly different vantage point,
engaging with Kyle's talk today,
as well as offering us their own insights.
And so we are delighted
to have Dr. Zenna Tavares
who's at Columbia, who is also
here in the audience today,
who will be leading the discussion session
and framing some of the open questions
and engaging with the material
that Kyle will be presenting today.
And these sessions have been
wonderful lively discussions
and really look forward to it.
So Zenna and Kyle will be in conversation
next Wednesday at 4:00 PM.
And to quickly give you a
preview of coming attractions,
we have Carl Zimmer who will be speaking
as part of the "Distinguished
Speaker Series"
about his new book, "Life's Edge,"
and that's at the end
of March, March 30th.
And then we have our "Mapping
As Knowing" lecture series
continuing with Victor Coello in April.
And we have a bunch of our
own Franke fellow speaking
later on in April.
Anyway, without further ado,
let me now turn it over to Kyle.
Kyle, we are delighted.
I wish we could have hosted you in person,
both Kyle and Zenna, but
things are as they are.
I think we are just really
grateful and deeply appreciative
of you agreeing to speak
to us on Zoom, thank you.
- Thank you very much, Priya,
for the warm introduction
and thank you, Zenna,
for agreeing to the
conversation next week.
I'm really looking forward to it.
Let me share my screen here,
hopefully this is fine.
Okay, does that look good?
- Yep, looks great.
- Great.
- Gonna hide you so I can see
a little bit better, okay.
So yeah, I'm really excited
to be invited in this series.
It's been really interesting.
I've been able to watch
quite a few of the talks,
not all of them, but I think most of them,
as well as the discussions
and conversations
that have followed, which I
find to be really interesting.
I like the format a lot.
So thank you very much for having me.
I think I'm maybe the last
one of this particular slate,
but maybe they'll be added some more.
So I tried to take on
a little bit of a role
of referring back to
some of the other talks
that happened in the series.
And so the title I chose is
Causality at the
Intersection of Simulation,
Inference, Science, and Learning,
and hopefully be able to see
how all these get tied together.
So I'm gonna start by
saying that there were a few
of the talks that happened earlier
where causality was being examined
and that word was being used
in a particular way
that physicists use it,
which has to do, for instance,
with things like the arrow of time,
the structure of space time.
That's my little diagram here.
This is some of, whoops,
excuse me, some event
and you have a future light
cone and a pass light cone,
and the notion of two
events being maybe separated
so that they're out of causal
contact with each other
and other points that are in
causal contact with each other,
trying to understand
that in the context of,
like I mentioned before, the arrow of time
or in the context of quantum
mechanics, et cetera.
And these were very interesting talks,
but there were some other talks
that were a slightly different
usage of the word causation,
which is more in the language
of sort of causal inference
and kind of from the
statistical point of view.
So there you have things
like here's my little picture
of a sun and the sun is
leading to hot sunny weather,
which kind of causes people
eating ice cream and sunburns.
And then that gives rise
to some kind of correlation
between ice cream and sunburns.
But we would probably all agree to say
it's wrong to say that
ice cream causes sunburns.
And so that's the typical correlation,
correlation, causation
aren't the same thing.
And so the mathematical framework
for trying to think about this
and causal reasoning was
sort of the subject of,
for instance, these two talks.
Now, after the talk by Jenann Ismael,
James Woodward was the
conversant that followed up.
And I grabbed a little
bit of the transcript
from their conversation 'cause I found it
to be very interesting and
it's kind of a nice entry point
into what I wanted to talk about today.
So James was pointing out
in response to the talk
that there were potentially
some interesting route
to be had on the philosophical side
by thinking about what he talked about,
a component that has a
more normative character.
Talked about the procedures
that make causal reasoning
or learning causal relationships
from certain kinds of data reliable.
And he said that these sort of
normative aspects of things,
when you do that, then you
bring in the connection
with statistics, causal reasoning,
machine learning, and AI,
and that it would be
interesting to sort of see
how these two ways of going
about the general topic
relate to each other.
And so I'm going to
definitely sort of follow up
from that a little bit.
And so, while I am,
my core discipline as a physicist,
I've been doing a lot of work
on machine learning and AI.
And a lot of what I have
to say kind of comes more
on the statistics side of things,
but they're of course very deeply related.
And so to try to kind of prime that,
just give a few graphic examples.
So here's a system.
It's a toy that I have
on my desk right now.
And when you see this kind of thing,
you see the balls bouncing around,
it sort of naturally draws to mind
a probabilistic description
of what's going on.
And of course, thinking about these kinds
of things are really
back in the early history
of our statistics and probability.
But if you think about
the system as it evolves,
when you describe it,
it's natural to think of
the balls bouncing either
to the left or to the right
with some probability.
And so you have this
probabilistic description
where the system evolves
in a stochastic way.
And now the same system, if
you look at it more closely
and in slow motion, you see
the balls bouncing around.
And now you're thinking maybe
more like classical mechanics
of a deterministic evolution of a system
where the balls are bouncing
through this lattice of pins.
And if you knew the
initial state perfectly,
you know it would unfold in
a totally deterministic way.
And so that kind of points
to this other notion
of causation that's more from
the physicist's point of view
and things like the arrow
of time and et cetera.
Now, if you want to try
to sort of reconcile
these two different ways of
looking at the same system,
we know that this is very sensitive
to the initial conditions.
And if you slightly perturbed the balls
at the very beginning, they
would take a different path
through the lattice of pins.
And so that, so each realization of
turning this desk toy over gives you
effectively some random outcome.
Now, this also happens
when you, for instance,
look at climate science.
These are simulations that are going on
of eddies inside of the oceans.
The description of this
is fluid mechanics.
So you have things like
Navier-Stokes equations,
again, that are deterministic.
There is some scale at
which you can't resolve
what's going on anymore.
And so you have this
kind of chaotic behavior.
And so there is a connection again to
randomness and stochasticity.
What is kind of interesting here,
the higher level picture is kind of looks
like deterministic and then,
but then you have some
lower level information
that you can't resolve,
so that introduces some
randomness into the system.
And then you have different
arrangements of this
and I guess there's just the observation
that as you sort of step through,
step down the reductionist ladder
or maybe step up the ladder
of emergent phenomena,
that you often see switches
in whether or not the kind
of effective description
that you're working with
looks stochastic or deterministic
and I think that's just kind
of an interesting observation.
So for instance, when you're
talking about thermodynamics
or thermostatics, you
have pressure and volume
and these kinds of quantities,
and there are equations that relate them
and it looks much more deterministic.
But we then understand
thermodynamics is arising
from an underlying statistical
mechanical description
of what's going on.
And then here, kind of
flipping the roles around,
this is supposed to be
the two-slit experiment.
And at the top, you see, for instance,
electrons hitting some screen
or something like that,
and the individual electrons
are like point-like particles,
and they have a random
nature that's associated
with the kind of randomness
of quantum mechanics.
But at the same time, we think of a kind
of underlying deterministic evolution
of the wave function due
to Schrodinger's equation.
So this is just basically to prime
that the two different ways of thinking
about causality and deterministic systems
and stochastic systems
are very closely related.
I'm going to be talking more
about stochastic systems,
but just keep in mind this relationship.
Now in the conversation
that I alluded to before,
later on about a half an
hour into the discussion,
James pointed out again
that this important
topic called scale separation,
which is essentially the
observation that if you wanted
to describe a bulldozer, you don't need
to bring in quantum mechanics
or quantum chromodynamics
to try to describe that.
And he says you could
imagine an alternative world
where to basically model anything,
you have to model all the way down
to the most detailed way.
But that doesn't seem how to be like
how our world is arranged and
that we often see some kind
of approximate decoupling
between the different scales
and that facilitates causal
reasoning in our world.
And I 100% agree with that,
and I'm gonna sort of show
some examples of that.
So now moving on to the kind of,
the topic of the series as inference,
and of course it's related
to causation and correlation.
And so the way that I'm going
to be talking about it is
that in the context of
some scientific theory,
for instance, as a particle
physicist, we have theories
and those theories often
have some parameters of,
call those theta, and
then I can use that theory
to make predictions about what I will see
in a particular experiment.
And so I'm making
predictions about the data,
which I call x here.
And the process of inference
is sort of the inverse of that.
From some data I would
like to infer something
about the theory that's in question.
And that can be done in
various different ways.
You know, often it's
phrased in the context
of Bayesian inference where
if you wanna say something
probabilistic about a
theory, given some data,
via Bayes theorem, you can relate that
to a statement about the probability
of the data, given the theory,
so this is what's called
the likelihood function,
and then times a prior
probability for the theory.
Now in particle physics, I'll
just make a quick comment
that the prior probability for the theory
is a very thorny, thorny thing.
It's not like what's the prior probability
that you have the flu
or something before you,
or you have COVID before
you take a COVID test.
Here, you're talking about like,
does some fundamental particle
exist in the universe or not?
And it's hard to talk about
that in a probabilistic way,
other than through more like
subjective notions of belief.
But this term, the likelihood
function is sort of
very well-grounded and how we
as physicists take a theory
and turn that into predictions about
what we expect the data to look like.
And I'm not going to get into the issues
of Bayesian versus frequentist
statistics, really,
other than just to
point out it's an issue.
The main thing I'm gonna
be you focusing on here
is the details and difficulties
with the probability
of the data, given the theory
or the likelihood function.
And so I'll come back to that later,
but this is sort of roughly
the probabilistic way
in which I'll be discussing inference.
Now, this is a picture
of an actual collision
that happened in 2012
and on the 10th of June
at the Large Hadron Collider
in the Atlas Experiment that I work on.
And obviously it's a computer rendering
of an actual collision
that happened in the data.
I'll talk about it a little bit
in some more detail in a moment.
This was one of approximately
a quadrillion collisions
at the Large Hadron Collider
that happened in those couple years.
So there were many, many
collisions like this,
but this one was one that
was particularly important
because it was a candidate
for being consistent
with the production of the Higgs boson.
So we had more collisions
that were like that
and we did some statistical
analysis of the data,
which I'll say a little bit more about,
and that's what led to the claim
of the discovery in July of 2012.
And one of the things that's
interesting about this is this,
really within about a week of that,
was one of the kind of
breakthrough milestone papers
in deep learning.
And that's when we really
started seeing deep learning
as we think of it today in
the context of image analysis,
image classification, really
starting to work quite well.
And very shortly after this,
you started getting situations
where deep neural networks
were sort of claims
of superhuman performance
and things like this.
So, this was definitely
a mile milestone moment,
both from the point of
view of deep learning
and from particle physics.
And for me personally, right after this,
I went on sabbatical and that's kind of,
I really shifted my
focus to thinking about
how to put these two together.
How can we take advantage
of what's going on
in machine learning and deep learning
for the purposes of doing science,
and what does that relationship look like?
And this was interesting because
it's kind of the backdrop
of a debate that's happening
across all the sciences,
where you see a pendulum swinging,
essentially from, in
the context of physics,
you had traditional approaches
to analyzing the data
where you have more handcrafted
types of data analysis
largely guided by expert
knowledge and theoretical insight.
Switching over to something
that's really started,
even a decade or more before
with the rise of big data
and data science and deep learning.
And there's a push to be
ever more data-driven,
in the context of machine learning,
you use this phrase end-to-end learning.
And that basically is hinting at sort of
a shooing expert knowledge
and what's sometimes referred
to as hand-designed features
and things like this, and really try
to have an end-to-end system driven by
with some deep neural network
or something in the middle
that tries to go from the data directly
to solving your problem.
So that would be something
like data from the LHC to, yes,
you discovered the Higgs
or not like in one step.
And so that's a very different approach,
and this is paired with the kind of desire
that maybe AI is somehow like magical
and it's just gonna look at all the data
and figure things out.
And it's, again, paired with a discussion
that started really with big data
about these kinds of, I would say,
somewhat ridiculous claims
that we're looking at, "the
end of theory," and that,
"the data deluge makes the
scientific method obsolete."
Quotes like this, that,
"All models are wrong
"and increasingly you can
succeed without them."
And you're given
everything that's going on,
it's hard to just dismiss these claims
because something is happening.
But so that's partially
what we wanna look into
a little bit more deeply
is to what degree is this,
are we witnessing some
kind of radical change
in the scientific method and
what does that look like?
So I'm gonna switch now to kind of
contrast what I was just
saying on the big data side
with the go back to the
more traditional approach,
and then start to bring
in elements of causation.
And I'll also say that while
physicists are very comfortable
with talking about causation
in the sense of space and time
and these kinds of things,
oftentimes we are not
particularly well trained
in the language of causal
inference and things like this.
It's actually something that's
very core, for instance,
in the social sciences
and in medical sciences
and sometimes in particle physics
or other areas of physics.
The causal relationship is so obvious
that it's not really
something that you needed
to develop a sort of
calculus to understand.
And so in that way, we're playing catch-up
but at the same time, a lot of the success
of physicists has been based
on leveraging causality,
notions of causality.
And so that's a kind of interesting thing
to try to reconcile.
It's partially what I'm,
thinking about a lot these days.
So this is a picture
with me and Judea Pearl
who wrote this "Book of
Why," and one of the,
in his book and in his writings,
he talks about what he calls
the latter of causation.
And he's saying the lowest rung
of the ladder is association.
So that's really at the
level of like correlations.
And so what you see is sort
of seeing and observing
where you just have data, basically.
And the point here is that
there are a set of questions
that you can address when
you have a lot of data,
but there are other types of questions
that you cannot address just with data.
So the idea that the big
data is gonna solve all
your problems is really only restricted
to this lowest rung on the ladder.
And in fact, there are
higher-level questions
where you want to ask questions like,
"What would happen if I do the following,"
if you intervene on the system.
And those kinds of
questions cannot be answered
just through data alone.
They really require
essentially some other kind
of structure that you add to it,
usually in the form of
some kind of assumption,
and I will give a concrete
example in just a moment.
But before doing so, I'll just say
that there's even a
higher level of question
in which are referred
to as counterfactuals,
where you're imagining
and you're sort of
answering questions like,
"What would have happened if
I had done the following?"
And so that's interesting
because you're sort of conditioning
on things that actually happen.
So you kind of, in principle,
can't answer that question
because it already happened,
while in the context of interventions,
you could make the interventions
and actually see what happens, right?
So these are the three levels
and they do have a very grounded,
formal mathematical basis,
which I'm not gonna go
into, but just to say,
they're not squishy concepts.
They're really very formalized,
well-defined concepts.
So let me give a concrete example.
This is, here you see some code.
As I said, there's three very
short little computer programs
where you have random variables, x and y,
and here you also have
a random variable z.
And then there's a little
drawing that's associated to it.
So here, the story is that the
random variable x was first,
and then it sort of causes y.
And you see, in the
program, x was generated
through the random number generator first,
and then y depends on x.
So this is the direction of causation.
Here, you see the opposite,
y is generated first
and then x is generated
and it's a function of y.
And then finally you have a
different situation where z,
z is a third variable that's generated
and then y and x both depend on z.
Okay, fine, so, and
here's the little drawing
associated to that.
Now, why is this interesting?
The reason that this
is interesting is here
there's three different stories about
how the data came to be,
the data generating process, but all three
of them give you exactly
the same joint distribution,
or the correlations between
x and y are exactly the same
in these three different stories.
So in that sense, if you just had data,
you wouldn't able to answer
which of these three is
responsible for producing the data.
But if you can do interventions,
if you can go in there and
like poke inside the system,
and for instance, set the variable x
to be a particular value,
and that's the notation here is do(X).
The do operator means
you're going and intervening
and if it was a simulator,
what you would do is you just,
at every step of the program,
you just make sure x is equal to three.
So you just see extra lines stuck in there
where you force x to be three.
And if you do that, then
if you look at the data
that comes out of this thing,
x will be three, no surprise there,
but the distribution
of y will be different
in these different cases.
And so that points to the fact
that if you can do interventions,
you can answer a richer set
of questions than you can
if you look at just data alone.
Okay, so you need to be able
to make those kinds of interventions
and I'll come back to that later.
Okay, so that is all a
little bit of a preamble
and now I'm going to switch to a topic
which is sort of near
and dear to my heart,
which I refer to as a
simulation-based inference.
So I'm gonna try to sort
of set it up broadly,
give a feel for why it's important,
and tie it back to some
specific examples in physics.
And then later we'll go
back to kind of science
and machine learning and
causation and things like that.
Okay, so the first slide in this section
starts with the observation
that science is replete
with high-fidelity simulations.
Okay, so we have simulators
for our particle colliders
at the Large Hadron Collider.
We have simulations for neuronal activity.
We have simulations for
how epidemics spread.
gravitational lensing
and the evolution of the
universe on the largest scales.
We have simulators for how
air moves around an airplane,
which we use to design airplanes,
and simulations for how proteins will fold
and things like that,
which helps us into the
design of drugs and et cetera.
And these simulators, what's
interesting about them is
not only can you use them
to generate synthetic data,
they are causal models of
the data generating process.
They actually have some mechanism of
what you think is happening, right?
So in the case of proteins,
you have atoms and molecules,
and they're maybe surrounded
by water, bumping into them,
and you have energy for some arrangement
and the system evolves in a certain way.
For epidemics, you have
individual people maybe
that you're modeling,
and they may get sick
or not with some probability
and that system evolves in some way.
And so, you can imagine in that simulator,
for instance, intervening,
like, "What happened if I
like held onto the protein
"and pulled it in a certain
way, what would happen?"
Or in the epidemics, you
could do a simulation of
what would happen if everyone
got a vaccine, for instance.
So the fact that their
causal is very important.
And now, as you'll see
throughout the talk,
there's a kind of computational bent
to a lot of the way that
I'm thinking about things.
And so it's important to
recognize that the expressiveness
of programming languages
and the modern computing
and all of this allows us
to really scale this up
and actually simulate these
very complicated systems
and make some very
high-fidelity simulations.
And that's something, that's a capability
we didn't have 50 years ago.
And so this is definitely changing the way
that we do science.
But as you'll see in a second,
it's a little bit out of step
with the way that we approach
statistics currently.
And so that's the point here, basically,
is that unfortunately, these simulators,
while they produce very
high-fidelity simulated data,
are poorly suited for
statistical inference.
And so why is that?
Well, let me try to give you
some feel for why that is.
So before doing that,
I'm just gonna lay out a
little bit of notation.
So I talked earlier about,
on the left side here,
I have basically the theory.
It has some parameters
which I'm calling theta.
And those might be, for instance,
in the case of COVID or something,
it might be like, how
virulent is this new virus?
How quickly does it double
as it goes through the population?
It could be a parameter like
the cosmological constant
of the universe, or the mass
of the Higgs boson, what have you.
So you have these kinds
of parameters over here,
and then the simulator allows you
to make predictions for the observed data.
It's not gonna just be,
the observed data's not gonna
have a particular value.
It's gonna have many possible values.
So it's gonna describe a
probability distribution
over the observed data.
But inside the simulation,
there might also be other random variables
that are referred to as latent variables,
which are part of the story
of how the data came to be,
even though you might not be able
to actually observe
them in your experiment.
So I'll give some examples,
but you could imagine that for instance,
in the case of COVID,
x might just be like hospitalization rates
or something like that, or people testing,
how many people tested
positive with COVID?
The latent variable
would be something like
how many people actually have COVID?
You don't know that.
But if you're doing a simulation,
you would have access to that variable.
So then, the question
of this inverse problem
or of inference is to go from the data x
to say the parameters of interest theta.
Now here's that same desk toy.
Now I'm just going to, I
don't know if you can see it,
here's the actual toy.
You can imagine, I want to introduce
some notion of a parameter.
So let's say I tilt the toy to the left,
or I tilt the toy to the right.
If I tilt it one way,
it's going to bias the distribution
so that it doesn't look the same.
So imagine that I want to try
to infer this parameter theta
which is say like how
tilted the whole toy is.
I could relate that
maybe with a probability
that a ball bounces to the right.
And so that's the thing
that I want to infer
and I'm gonna do that
based on the distribution
of where the balls land at the bottom.
And I'm gonna call the location
where they land at the bottom x.
And then the latent
variable would be the path
that the balls took through
this lattice of nails, okay?
And, in principle, I could
maybe go observe that,
but I wasn't paying any
attention, it was too fast.
So really, all I get to
observe is where they landed
and I'm gonna think of the path
that they took as the latent variable.
So if you wanna predict
what is that distribution,
well, you might say,
okay, well, I can do that.
It's either gonna bounce to the left
or to the right with some probability.
There's many possible paths,
but there's some nice
symmetry that's there.
and if you took your combinatorics class,
then you can figure out what
that distribution should look like.
And there it is at the bottom,
it's the binomial distribution.
Okay, so you would assume this
is the binomial distribution
as I did once before teaching a class
on the subject to undergraduates.
But then I compared that to
what it actually looks like
and it doesn't match up.
And then I was a little confused as to why
and then I took the slow-motion video
that I showed you before,
and if you look closely,
you'll see that the balls are
not just going left and right.
They're bouncing all over the place.
Sometimes they skip
over two or three pins,
they run into each other,
it's a lot more complicated, right?
So if you wanted to say
what's the distribution
here down at the bottom,
I have no idea what that distribution is,
but I can simulate it.
And that's kind of part of the point.
So here's an example of a simulation
for this exact thing done by
my colleague, (indistinct)
and I know it looks very realistic.
It looks a lot like that
video I just showed you.
You don't know exactly
how bouncy the balls are,
how big the nails, or
the pins are, et cetera,
but you can simulate it.
And symbolically, if you ask yourself,
what's the probability distribution
of the data landing in these
different bins at the bottom,
given the parameter that
says like how tilted it is,
symbolically, it's equal to,
don't be worried about the math too much.
This integral just means I'm going
to sum over all the possible trajectories
that the balls could take
that would give you that same observation.
The problem now is that
I can't do that sum
with nice mathematical
tricks of combinatorics
'cause there's no like
nice structure anymore
to take advantage of.
And this latent space of
different possibilities
is growing very, very rapidly.
And so that means that
basically this integral
that I want to perform
where I sum over all the different
paths is now intractable.
And that means that the likelihood,
the thing that relates to the probability
of the data given the
parameters is not available
to me anymore in any practical sense.
And so here, I would say that
the likelihood is intractable
and that means that basically all
of the different approaches
for doing statistical inference require
that you have the likelihood,
and so like, what do
you do now, basically?
So while that, the
likelihood is intractable,
I can still generate
synthetic observations
with my simulator.
And so it seems like you should be able
to make some kind of progress
by basically comparing the outcome
of the simulations to the actual data.
And so then the question is just
how are you going to do that in practice?
So let me go back to the
Large Hadron Collider
and tell a slight, the same story,
but with a more complicated,
real-world science experiment.
So here's the very complicated data
at the Large Hadron Collider.
It's very high dimensional.
The detector has about
100,000 sensors on it.
And so when I want to make a
prediction of what will happen,
I start off with a theory, which is based
on quantum mechanics
and quantum field theory
that we call the standard model.
It has some parameters.
I can then use that theory, I don't know,
maybe you've seen things
like Feynman diagrams,
sort of pictorial representations
that allow me to calculate
what would happen,
what's the probability that the particles
are gonna scatter off of
each other in a certain way
and that this interaction will take place.
This interaction has a Higgs boson in it
that decays into some
other particles called Z's
that decay into other things.
Doesn't really matter.
But these particles over
here on the right are coming,
flying out into the detector.
The problem is that we
don't see those directly.
Instead, there's another process
where they radiate and
it becomes really messy.
And at this stage,
I can't write down what's going on
like really on a pencil and paper.
I can describe what happens kinda locally.
Every time you see one
of these splittings,
I can write down a probability.
But the whole process is
this very complicated thing.
And so I can put it on a computer,
but it's very difficult to work with
with a pencil and paper.
So you go from the latent
variables that were associated
with this first stage,
followed by latent variables,
random variables that
I don't get to observe,
followed with this
complicated showering process,
is what it's called.
Then these particles
are physical particles
that come flying and
smash into our detectors
and they ionize and they
run into pieces of metal
and they do all the things that they do.
And then there are literally hundreds
of millions of latent variables associated
with how these particles interact
with our gargantuan detectors.
And finally you get observed
you electronic signals
in our detector, which
is like the raw data
that is collected by these experiments,
and so that's x.
And so if I wanna think
about how do I simulate that,
I just told you the physical story,
there's actually software
for each one of these stages.
And you can think of
these different programs
as basically encoding these
probability distributions
that go from one step to the
next step, to the next step.
And it's really kind of hopping
from the smallest scales
to the next scale,
to the next scale, in
some probabilistic way,
until you get to the final observations.
And we call these Monte Carlo generators
and that's because Monte
Carlo is a technique
that you can see as a way of trying
to integrate these random variables.
So symbolically, you could write down
this simulation this way.
You're saying basically the likelihood
of the observations
given the data is equal
to this integral of this
product of probabilities.
But this integral is like
100-million-dimensional
and there's no way that you're going
to do that, basically.
Like, this is a totally
intractable integral in practice.
So that means that the
likelihood is intractable here.
So what do you do?
Like, how is it that we
discovered the Higgs boson
if we're in this kind of setting, right?
So what we have done
as a field for decades
and other fields have kind of
developed their own version
of this ranging from
genomics to cosmology,
to all over the place,
is that you use your kind
of domain knowledge,
your expert knowledge,
to think about like, well,
what is it about the data
that's going to be useful
for testing the hypothesis
that I have in mind?
And that turns into
basically in the context
of the particle physics, taking
very high-dimensional data
from the detector and then
distilling 100 million
electronic sensor readouts
into just one number,
which is the horizontal axis in this plot,
which I'm going to then
make a histogram of.
And I'm gonna histogram the data
so every collision I have just one number
and I have many collisions,
so I build a histogram,
and that's like the black
dots in the histogram.
And the red histogram is basically
what I predict from my theory.
And the important part is
that I can sort of fill
that histogram up with
a bunch of simulations.
So if I step back and
like look at the text
on the slide here, and statistically,
you would say this one variable
that distills all the information
from this high-dimensional data
is called a summary statistic.
That's what a statistician would call it,
sometimes related to feature engineering
is what a machine learning
person might call it.
Coming up with this summary
quantity is basically the task
of a skilled physicist.
And then we try to
estimate the distribution
of the summary statistic, here
are these like histograms,
using just something
simple like a histogram.
So if we look at this
picture of this collision
that I showed you earlier
which was a candidate
for the Higgs boson,
we have this very high-dimensional data,
what does the process look like
that we take this high-dimensional data
and we distill it into a single number?
Well, the first part we
kind of take for granted,
like you can see in the picture,
there are these, for instance,
these four red lines.
If you ask a particle
physicist, they'll say,
"Oh, these are four muons
"that were reconstructed
from the particular signals
"that they leave inside of the detector,"
because muons have this
interesting property
that they can punch their way all the way
through all of this material,
there's like several meters of
lead and iron and et cetera.
So they can go all the way through that,
but they ionize on their way out
and that leaves a little trace
of energy deposits along the way.
And so we can see those energy deposits
and then we can identify
them and then say,
"Yes, we think there was a muon here."
We can say if it was a positive
or negatively charged one.
We can estimate its
energy and its direction
and then that's basically all there is
to say about that muon.
And so then in this example,
we have four of them.
So we don't, there's already lots
of philosophical
questions here about like,
how do you know that that's a muon?
You don't really see the muon.
You see the energy
deposits in the detector.
But this concept of a muon has
served physicists very well.
We see muons in all sorts
of different experiments
and we can predict what
they're gonna look like
and that's exactly what
we see in the data.
So physicists generally
believe that the idea
of muons are real, right?
So if I take these four
muons, that's great.
Maybe I can sort of see
them in my detector.
But what about the Higgs?
Well, if I produced the
Higgs in this collision,
it would've decayed instantaneously
and never even made it
to the next atom over
before it decayed.
So we're never going
to see the Higgs boson
in our detector directly.
So how do we know if we made a Higgs?
Well, we want to try to somehow
basically sequentially
invert the causal process
of how the data came to be.
So first we identified these muons
and now we wanna think about,
okay, well, where do the muons come from?
And then we're going to exploit things
that we know, like relativity.
So maybe you're familiar
with E equals MC squared.
That's not really what Einstein said.
That only kind of works
if nothing's moving.
If something's moving,
then you can sort of square both sides
and add an extra component that
has to do with the momentum.
So you'd say the energy
is related to the mass
and the momentum through this equation.
But I don't see the Higgs particle.
So how do I use this equation?
Well, you can take advantage of energy
and momentum conservation.
So if there was a Higgs that was produced,
the energy that it had was kind of
like the energy beforehand,
turns into the energy after,
which is the energy that I
would have in those four muons.
And similarly, the momentum for the Higgs
is the momentum before,
turns into the momentum after,
turns into the sum of the
momentum and those four muons.
So I can take this
equation and this equation
and put them together and rearrange it.
And basically if I'm
producing Higgs bosons
and the Higgs bosons
have a well-defined mass,
then this particular combination
of things should basically
always give me the same number up
to like measurement uncertainties.
So let's see what it
looks like in the data.
That's this quantity that I just told you.
For every collision, I
calculate that equation
I just showed you and I
get a particular number
and I histogram it.
And then I can do that
with both real data.
Those are the black dots,
and then I can do it with simulated data.
So if I take the simulation of
what I expect from normal processes
that I already know about
in particle physics,
I expect the blue histogram
that's sort of sitting on
top of the screen histogram,
and that's basically plays the
role of our null hypothesis.
That's what we expect to see
if there is no Higgs particle.
And these are the little Feynman diagrams
that correspond to those processes.
But if I'm producing the Higgs,
I expect to see something
else, I have a new process,
and so I expect to see a
bump sitting on top of it.
And so that's the prediction
and you see there's this very
sharp feature in the data,
this very sharp bump.
And the fact that it's a
sharp feature is important.
And the reason that
the way that I was able
to use my domain knowledge
to take the very complicated
from the LHC data and come up
with this very sharp feature
is like a testament to what
physicists are good at, right?
And so as you can already see,
the data look like they prefer a bump,
and as we collected more and more data,
the evidence for the
bump became very obvious.
And that is the, basically
the experimental signature
that we found the Higgs.
But we didn't just do that
in the one example that I showed you.
This one, we did it
across literally hundreds
of different ways that you might expect
to see the Higgs particle in the LHC data,
and they're all related to each other.
And this is where this collaborative,
statistical modeling framework
that Priya alluded to came into play.
And this is just a graph of the like,
the computer, like the computer program
that we used to calculate the probability
of the data, given the parameters.
It's pretty complicated,
but it's really like classical statistics.
And the fact that we're able to relate all
of these different kinds of
parts of the data is, again,
like shows the strength of the fact
that our theory has this causal nature
that allows us to relate all of these
to different parts of the data together.
So then we analyzed
this and unsurprisingly,
we found the Higgs and
we claimed the discovery.
So I showed you this picture
before the slide previously
so that we took the high dimensional data
and we boiled it down
into the summary statistic
and this has worked pretty well.
So this is an example of
simulation-based inference
where this histogram,
the red histogram is
basically playing the role.
It's approximating the probability
of the data, given the theory
and I can calculate that from simulations.
The problem with this approach though,
is it does not work well
if you don't have a really
good summary statistic.
And if you want to, for instance,
work with like more like the raw data
or your summary is like a
higher-dimensional thing,
then this approach is not gonna scale.
Now, basically, you're never gonna have
enough simulated data to make
a high-dimensional histogram.
And that's related to this thing
called the curse of dimensionality.
So the that's a bit of a problem.
And so the interesting thing
that's happening right now,
which is using machine
learning, in some sense,
in a very traditional way,
is since you can use your simulator
to produce a lot of synthetic data,
it's a very good match
for machine learning.
And what people have
figured out how to do,
and I've made some
contributions here myself,
is figure out how can we
use the simulated data
and then the value of the
parameters that we know,
'cause we use them when
we ran the simulator,
to try to get a neural
network or something else,
some other kind of machine-learning model
to effectively approximate the likelihood
or the likelihood ratio, or the posterior,
one of these statistics objects
that we need for doing inference?
And basically it's just
a way of getting around
this intractable integral
that I referred to earlier.
And so in that sense, it's very practical,
but it's also very profound
because it's giving us like really,
like superpowers across all
sorts of different areas
of science and it's
happening like right now.
And I think it's like a very
important, profound moment
in the evolution of statistics.
Previously, there were really big jumps
that happened in statistics when you went
from having to solve problems
with just pencil and
paper and using calculus,
to where you could, for instance,
if you didn't know how to find the minimum
or maximum of a function,
you could use a numerical optimizer.
Or if you didn't know how
to integrate something
with a pencil and paper,
you could use numerical
integration techniques.
Now we're at the point where
the likelihood function itself
is not tractable and we're
able to use machine learning
to basically fill in that gap
and give us a good
approximation of the likelihood,
which then allows us to go back
to do kind of classical
statistical inference.
So this is a really important point.
And it's allowing scientists
of various stripes
to be able to work kind of directly
with the low-level raw data.
Maybe not have some
good insight about like,
what is a good summary?
But you're not throwing
away your expert knowledge.
Your expert knowledge is in the simulator
and you're using machine learning as a way
of basically transferring
the expert knowledge
from the simulator onto the surrogate,
which is some sort of
neural network or something.
And so, it's, again, I say
it's all very practical,
but it has profound implications.
Okay, so, yeah, so if I
step back a little bit
and say, think about what's going on,
you know, as I mentioned before,
there are all these areas of science
that have these well-motivated
mechanistic models
that are the simulators,
machine learning is basically providing
an ability to effectively gap,
bridge the gap between some
low-level microscopic phenomena
that interact in some
way that's intractable,
to some effective statistical model
for some higher-level quantities,
some other higher-level phenomena.
And so it's kind of like the
more like emergent phenomena
and you're able to bridge those
two in some effective way.
And so I think that if you want
to be able to do this reliably,
there's a question of like
how much simulated data do you need?
And this is where sometimes,
if you don't have a smart way of doing it,
this is where it's going to require
an enormous amount of simulated data
and this whole approach
is doomed to failure.
But if there's something
that makes this work,
then that's important.
Part of the secret sauce here
is essentially causality.
And this is where I think it connects
to what James Woodward referred to
as the more normative aspects
about relating causality
and causal inference.
Okay, so I'm looking at the time here.
I realize I'm going slower
than I had intended,
hopefully for the benefit of clarity.
But okay, so I'm gonna switch a little bit
and don't be alarmed if I kind
of skip over a few slides.
So, okay.
So what I just talked
about was sort of one part
of kind of the bigger scientific method.
This is one of these kind of toy drawings
of the scientific method, which is,
I don't really believe
the scientific method
has a flowchart associated to it.
But if there is one, I
prefer this one compared
to the other ones that I
find with a Google search.
But the thing that I
wanted to focus on here is
that this part about gathering
data and testing predictions,
that's essentially the part
that I was just describing.
We're using machine learning
to enable statistical inference
essentially for doing
hypothesis testing, okay.
And so that, so you can either
see it testing predictions
or maybe it's about
rejecting a hypothesis.
So it's kind of isolated to
this part of this flowchart.
Nowhere in there is there a
part that's about thinking
of interesting questions,
formulating hypotheses,
developing testable predictions,
trying to figure out what
experiment should you do?
All of those parts of
the scientific method
are not reflected in what
I just described at all.
So if you want to try to incorporate them,
what is that gonna look like, right?
So here is where you kind of
start to connect to other ideas
and machine learning that
are more closely related
to what's called like
reinforcement learning.
So maybe you're aware of
the news that happened.
Surprisingly, this was
six years ago today.
March 9th, 2016 is when one of these,
AlphaGo, one of these
reinforcement learning,
deep neural network
type approaches was able
to beat Lee Sedol in a game of Go.
And if you think about what's happening,
there's an iterative type of interaction
between sort of the AI
agent in some environment,
which is like the
opponent on the Go board,
and the AI agent is trying to
decide what move to make next.
And this looks a little bit like,
here in reinforcement
learning, you have an agent,
it takes some action,
interacts with the environment,
and then there's some
sort of updated state,
and maybe you get, the
agent gets a reward,
which would be something like are they
in a better position on the board or not?
But this looks a lot like,
for instance, a scientist
in that your scientist is the agent trying
to decide, What experiment
should I perform next?"
And then when they actually decide that,
they interact with the
environment, which is actually
like performing the
experiment, gathering data.
Then the interpreter is basically
the statistical analysis.
And the updated state is
essentially, for instance,
like the Bayesian update
from your prior knowledge
to your posterior belief, right?
And so this is kind of a
nice, like schematic of
what experimentation looks like
that connects with machine learning.
And this can all be formalized.
I'm not gonna go through this,
but this is the formalizing
it in the language
of statistical decision theory,
you see things like states of
nature, types of observations,
what kind of actions you want to take.
And again, you see
these normative concepts
like loss functions and risk
and all of these kinds of things.
And then you can basically evaluate
how well a particular
strategy is working or not.
So if you wanted to
design a new experiment,
you might say that, like the
thing that I'm going to use
to decide which experiment
to perform next,
or which intervention I
want to perform is the one
that is going, an expectation is going
to move me from my prior degree of belief
to a posterior degree of belief
where the information gain is maximized.
And you can formalize all of that
and in these equations, not so important.
Any, oh, but I should say
what is important is the way
that the fact that you're
able to answer this question,
like, what do I expect would happen
if I do a certain intervention?
The only way you can answer
a question like that is
if you have a causal model.
And so, because the
simulator is a causal model,
I can actually answer this question.
And then if you look
the different quantities
that pop up in here,
priors and posteriors,
if you have a simulator,
then you get back into the situation
where the likelihood is intractable,
but you can take advantage
of these simulation-based inference things
to try to incorporate the two
and do experimental design.
So here's a bit of a flowchart.
If I wanted to do experimental design
where I'm sort of trying to optimize
the expected information
gain of my next experiment,
I sort of do an experiment,
I get some data.
I use Bayes' theorem to update
my prior to a posterior,
and then I wanna optimize what's my next
experiment going to look like.
So that's some loop that I do
and what does it look like?
You can go through it, but basically,
now you sort of do the same
thing that's on the left,
but with simulated data that you expect
that you would see if you
do a certain intervention,
which you can calculate
'cause you have a simulator.
But this becomes, there's
like a, it's just very,
very expensive computationally to do this
because you have all
this stimulations inside
of loops inside of loops.
And so computationally, this is just,
it's doable, but it's
very, very expensive.
Now, I prototyped this
with some colleagues
and we were able to get a system
that could basically optimize
what beam energy should you
use for a particle collider
if you want to measure one
of the particular quantities
inside of the standard model,
called the weak mixing
angle, or the Weinberg angle.
And you can do that,
and it basically says,
okay, the expected information
gain has a function
of the center mass energy,
looks something like this.
And this agrees with what you expect,
if you've got a PhD in particle physics,
this is probably some
problem that you had to do
for homework at some point.
But what's interesting is
a graduate student can look
at the equations and can
just reason through it
without any of this computation and say,
"Yes, you should run like
at roughly this energy,
"that's where you're
gonna learn the most."
And that's exactly what the
experimentalists did, right?
So, it's cool that you can
operationalize this whole thing
with machine learning,
but it's very inefficient
and somehow humans have been able
to do this much more efficiently.
So after I put this
together, I tweeted about it,
Danilo Rezende, who's a well known
machine learning researcher
was like, "Oh, that's cool.
"You've got the whole scientific method
"in a Python notebook."
And it's half true, but it's
really in the most confined,
pristine case possible.
The simulator is well specified,
the space of experimental configurations
is very well specified, and
still it was hard to do.
So I guess what I would
draw attention to is
if you want to be able
to do something like this
and like humans do in a open world
of possible experimental configurations,
and you also want to include
hypothesis generation
and things like this,
modern AI is very far away
from being able to do that.
But that's interesting, right?
Like that's the path
that we want to go down.
Okay, so, yeah, so going back to this kind
of overall big picture
about the scientific method,
I think if we want to get to this point
where we have AI type systems
that are actually designing experiments,
formulating hypotheses,
where we're missing some,
it's not gonna be some
end-to-end learning,
deep neural network that has no structure,
it's going to, I think,
need to have components
that you can point to that
are organized in some way
that looks like some
kind of causal structure.
And it may not have the
same kind of ontology
that current physicists have.
It may be some foreign ontology.
But I think it's going to
need to have some ontology
of different kinds of components
that's at its essence causal,
and that it's gonna need to be able
to manipulate them effectively
if it's going to do
in a science and any
kind of reasonable way.
And I think thinking through
that is really important
for us trying to like put our finger
on what is it about
causality that's important?
And to what degree are we kind of,
should we expect that this,
like this future AI
system is going to arrive
at an ontology that
sort of maps one to one
onto ontology that physicists have
with electrons and muons and Higgs bosons
and things like that?
Maybe not, but it would be kind of a,
it would be a little bit surprising,
I would say, if it really didn't,
if there wasn't some correspondence there.
Okay, so, yeah, so this was just kind
of a editorial note
that if you think about
how humans do this, it's pretty amazing.
And when I think, when
I introspect unto myself
as a physicist, I
definitely have roughly five
or so different mental models
for experimental particle physics
that I bounce between at different scales.
And I choose the one,
(softly coughs) excuse me,
that's appropriate for a given task
and that's how I do physical reasoning.
And I have a very hard time seeing
how something that's only
working at the low level
of a simulator with
tracking the microscopic trajectories
of particles ionizing
off of atoms is going
to be able to cope with
the kinds of problems
that a human does that
can just quickly jump
to a very like stick-figure-like
picture of what's going on.
And I think that AI models are gonna need
to get to that point.
So in my last couple minutes,
I'm just gonna flash a
few things that are a view
from the machine learning and AI community
to basically try to say that this line
of thinking is not foreign to the AI
and machine learning community,
which to some degree,
I'm a part of myself now.
But just some concepts
that are floating around
in that discussion.
So one of them, there's something called,
the no free lunch theorem,
which basically says that
if you don't make any assumptions
and you imagine all the possible
like machine learning
problems that you might have,
like all the possible data distributions
that essentially there is no,
every algorithm is going
to perform equally well
to every other algorithm on average.
So if one algorithm is
doing better than another,
it somehow has to be leveraging
something that's atypical.
And so if you think about, say, images,
if you don't add any structure,
something on the left here,
that's the typical image.
It's just some random noise, right?
That's what most images look like that.
But natural images don't
look like that at all.
They have all sorts of
structure and smoothness
and all sorts of things going on.
So the effectiveness of like convolutional
neural networks and
things has something to do
with the fact that they're
exploiting the structure
that's of actual natural images.
And otherwise, things like
curse of dimensionality,
you would naively think that
it should basically never work.
Stephane Mallatt is a
well known researcher,
did work with wavelets
and things like that.
So he's talking about learning physics
with deep neural networks and points
to two really central pillars,
if you want to hope
that this is gonna work.
And one of them is finding symmetries
and the other one is separating phenomena
at different scales.
So we've already seen
that a few different times
and the convolutional neural networks,
they incorporate both of these ideas.
The broader class of these types of ways
of adding something to the
model so that it will work
are referred to as inductive bias.
It's biased in the sense
that it's biasing towards,
to be effective towards
data of a certain type,
that has a certain characteristics,
and it's maybe not gonna
help in other situations.
So here you see scale separation symmetry,
the idea of compositionality,
the idea of relationships
between different objects and causality.
These are, I think, some
of the most important forms
of inductive bias.
You see Peter, like Peter Battaglia,
who's at DeepMind now and was previously
with Joshua Tenenbaum and company,
and has a background in
human and cognitive science,
talking about model building,
combinatorial generalization
sort of the infinite use of finite means,
and about these kinds of ideas
about intelligence and model building.
He's taken these ideas to
do really impressive work
that have to do with like
you're interested in studying
some physical system,
and you're gonna come up with
a neural network architecture
that has some structure associated to it
that's kind of a mirror of what you think
the actual physical system looks like.
I've worked with him on
some of these projects.
I think it's a very promising direction.
And then you see Stefanie,
who's at MIT talking about
a more formal version
of the same idea.
She calls it algorithmic alignment,
and she has some formal
theorems and things.
But it's some approach to try
to formalize this idea of
inductive bias, sorry about
the street noise here.
(sirens softly howling)
And then finally, this is
Yoshua Bengio talking about,
"Okay, dear machine learning community,
"what if we had the right causal structure
"in our neural networks?"
And the claim is that basically,
if you had these kind of
independent mechanisms
in your causal mechanism,
that you'll be able to
learn with many fewer samples,
that's referred to as sample complexity.
And that it'll be more
robust to things like
what's called distribution shift
or domain shift and things like this.
The idea that if like
the data that you use
for training is not exactly
the same as the data
that you're trying to apply
it to in the real world,
it'll be more robust.
And you see various discussion
from other luminaries
in machine learning.
So these are very much on people's mind.
These topics are very
much on people's mind.
And what I'm interested in is the fact
that the kind of traditional direction
that's coming from physics
and this kind of modern
machine learning thinking
is coming together at the same time
and the role of causality
is very important.
So I already mentioned basically
this idea of trying to,
the importance of machine learning
for simulation-based inferences.
But you also see this idea
that if you can incorporate
what you know about the
data generating process
into the machine learning
models themselves,
that that can basically
help with sample complexity.
And it's kind of a path towards
how AI might actually start
to learn the underlying causal mechanism,
which I think is on the
path towards AI generating
hypotheses and designing experiments.
And then lastly, I'd
just say that there's,
going back to some of
John Woodward's points,
is that this way of framing it
and thinking about it allows you
to basically do experiments where you can,
the simulators basically,
they have a ground truth
data generating process
where you're not arguing about
what the actual causal story is
because it's right there in front of you
in your computer program.
And then you can look to see what kind of,
how effective is it to impose this type
of inductive bias on the model
and how much does that help in terms
of these like normative aspects about,
that bring together causation
and causal reasoning?
And with that, I will say thank you
and remind you that next
week on Wednesday at 4:00 PM,
I have a follow up discussion with Zenna
and I'm looking forward to that very much.
Thank you much, very much.
- Thank you so much, Kyle,
for that absolutely fantastic talk.
Very, very clear exposition
and I really appreciate the
fact that you put effort
into combining and putting
together the various threads
that previous speakers and the directions
that previous speakers
in the series have taken
to address these issues.
I personally really appreciated
your showing the differences
in the meaning of causality,
the different meanings of
causality that have been used
and how they actually
relate to each other.
So there are questions
lining up in the chart,
but I'm jumping with one question myself.
So I'm gonna take this
(laughing drowns out
Priya) first, which is,
so, I loved your sort of
clarifying the process of inference
and how in a domain like physics,
the known laws actually guide
us and how replicating that.
So I was wondering, so in terms
of new discoveries, right?
So suppose there's a hitter
to unknown conservation law.
Because we are moving
using our domain knowledge
to come up with a suitable
summary statistic,
and just following the language
of the examples in physics.
So is it completely impossible,
because our summary statistic is limited,
because it's defined entirely
by what is known, prior knowledge,
that something that is hitter to unknown
will actually be mystic.
How would you capture,
I want to understand
how you could open up discovery space.
- Yeah, no, that's a great question.
So I think, the typical
way that we've gone around,
gone about designing summary
statistics has been guided
by how we think the data,
like our assumptions about
what's actually going on,
or there's a hypothesis we
don't know if it's true or not.
But if it were true, it has
the following consequences
and we can use that as a
guide for designing a summary
that's going to be very powerful, right?
But your other approaches that you can use
to kind of take the hide,
it's essentially like data compression,
you have high-dimensional data,
and you're going to distill it down
to some lower-dimensional thing.
And you'll discard some information
on the way, that's fine.
I mean, these summary statistics
that we use in particle
physics are good for one task,
but they're not good for other tasks.
So it's not surprising that you're
gonna throw away a lot of data.
But there are certainly
approaches where you try to
sort of learn, in machine learning,
they would be referred to as
a representation of the data.
You have the full data,
and then you have some representation
that will capture some
pieces of information,
but not others, right?
And so, there are all sorts of approaches,
including unsupervised learning,
or even what I was talking about
and what I showed with where
we are using neural network.
That neural network
surrogate, in some senses,
is a learned summary statistic.
But it's, again, it's learned
because it's targeting
a specific hypothesis.
If you wanted to do it
in a way that's like,
I think the essence of your question
where you're not assuming the hypothesis,
but you're trying to learn from data,
what would that look like?
And there certainly are various approaches
that are coming out now,
things that are related
to like anomaly detection
and stuff like that where you try
to essentially learn some representation,
which is good at capturing what
most of the data looks like
and then you look for something unusual
in some sense of unusual.
There's progress there but
it's a bit of a can of worms.
If you wanted to discover
something like a symmetry,
I think there are definitely
works there to try to,
how could you discover them?
One of them is you basically
sort of enumerate a bunch
of possibilities and then you basically--
- You brute-force it, right?
- It turns into,
Yeah.
- Yeah, you brute-force it,
but, you have to still
start with some prior
expectation, maybe it's even as silly
as dimensional analysis
or something, right?
But you have to just brute-force
through possibilities.
That's pretty clear.
So, hey, let me move on
to the first question,
which is somewhat
related, it's from Ferdos.
"What if we want to look at physics
"beyond the standard model?
"Where the theory is
an uncharted territory
"in a manner of speaking.
"So how do we hunt for these signatures?"
- Yeah, no, exactly.
So I think the, it's a
question that comes up a lot
in this talk, which is like,
"Well, that's great and all,
"but I wanna learn something
that's beyond my simulator,
"like, I wanna learn new physics."
So, one thing that's
important to realize is
that we don't just have a simulator
for like the standard model.
We have simulators for basically
all of the crazy thoughts
that theorists have come up
with over the last decades.
So we have a formalism that's
kind of general purpose.
And we describe, essentially,
every new physics theory
that we can think of
gets described in that formalism.
And the tools that we have can allow us
to make predictions of what
we would expect the data
to look like for kind of any theory
in that space of theories.
Now you could say, "I want
to go even beyond that,"
and ask about theories
that are not expressed
in that formalism.
And then, I guess what to say,
essentially, all kinds
of inferences are going
to be done at some point in
the context of a model, right?
So you need some notion of saying,
what do you think the data
is going to look like?
And that doesn't have to be expressed
in the language of quantum field theory.
It could be a very
empirically motivated way,
like signature based where actually,
like, "What if there's a bump in the data?
"What if the data does this?"
It doesn't have to be based
on quantum field theory or something.
And so then you can say,
"Well, I don't know exactly
what the bump looks like,
"but can you search for any
bump or any sharp feature?"
Or, "Does it ever have any kind of,"
if you don't say, add
some other assumption,
you just say anything other
than the standard model,
then you open yourself up
to a bunch of possibilities
that people don't wanna take seriously,
like electronic noise in your detector
that has no kind of structure to it,
that no one, no physicists
would look and be like,
"Ooh, new physics."
They'd just be like, "I've
got a cable that's loose,"
or something, you know?
But trying to figure
out how to balance that
between very well specified
theories that are so narrow
that they maybe seem uninteresting
and a completely open ended,
could be anything where you have no power,
finding that trade-off is challenging.
And so coming up with a
way to describe theories
in some kind of effective way
that people are happy with
that maintains some power
is kind of a transition that's happening.
Well, I mean, it's an old problem.
It's a classic problem in
statistics, but it's renewed.
It has renewed energy in the context
of machine learning now.
- Thank you very much.
The next question is
from Li Hao, Li Hao Yung.
"In my understanding, the state-of-the-art
"machine learning algorithms
really act like a black box.
"It's very difficult to interpret
"why the algorithm actually works.
"Would this reduce the
power of ML inferences?"
- By keeping it a black box
or by making something that's not a,
this meaning what I'm preferring?
- [Priya] Yeah.
- Well, I think that, yeah,
so let's see what to say.
So, that general idea of adding structure
to your architecture or
your model was referred to
as inductive bias, right?
So why is that term used?
Inductive, because you're
kind of adding some structure
to the model to try to, 'cause you're,
but the bias part is
because you're not giving,
you're not saying as
an equal playing field
to all possible scenarios
that the data could look like anything.
You're saying, "I think
the data has some kind of,
"is organized in some way."
It has some type of structure
and when you impose that,
then you are kind of,
you're favoring yourself
in that direction.
And so you're kind of
biasing yourself in that way.
Now, if the thing, if reality
actually has that structure,
then you're kind of, you're fine.
Like if the reality is there,
if reality's not quite
in that family of things,
then maybe you have a bit of a problem.
But generally, if you
can impose that structure
and it's like the right
thing, you're good.
Of course you don't know
if it's right or not.
So it's a tough question
to answer it generally.
But the other thing to say is
if you think about situations,
like there have been papers,
I referred to some of the work
by Peter Battaglia and company.
And there's a recent
paper by Miles Cranmer,
no relationship, who's
looking at, for instance,
planets moving around and trying to infer
what is the gravitational law?
And we've done some work like that.
Those kinds of models you can use
what are called graph neural network
where the nodes of the graph are things
that have physical meaning,
like planets or particles or atoms.
And the edges between
them have physical meaning
like force between two planets
or something like that.
And in that sense, you're
kind of doing the hard work
for the machine learning.
The machine learning algorithm didn't know
what planets were or that it wasn't some
like linear combination of
planets that should be a node.
It said like each planet should be a node
and there should be a one-way,
bidirectional relationship
that's symmetric
and all sorts of things.
And so you impose all that inducted bias,
but in that problem, you think it's right.
And if you do that, it just
helps tremendously, right?
If you take that away, you
could in principle get there,
but you're gonna need a lot more data
before you perform well.
- Great, thank you.
And there's of course a really
profound question from Brian.
"Thanks for this really fun
and accessible talk, Kyle.
"Could you talk a little bit about
"what you've been thinking
regarding the implications
"for epistemology and the
limits of human knowledge
"or information acquisition?"
- Yeah, that's a good one.
Yeah, I mean, I think, well, what to say?
I'm not like a trained philosopher,
so probably everything I will say
will sound like naive and et cetera.
But I do often like to
think of it in terms of
if some alien civilization
came and landed,
it would be clear that they are,
if they have the fancy
spaceships and stuff,
it's clear they have advanced technology.
You're not gonna be arguing about
if they're intelligent or not.
And it's clear that they probably
have some notion of science
or they probably wouldn't
have gotten there.
And so compared to other areas where,
like with AI, human-level AI,
where you're arguing about
what does it mean to be intelligent,
it's like this starting, this
framing, you're kind of not,
it's a very understandable
notion for I think most people
that, yes, they're intelligent,
they've got some notion of science.
And then you imagine starting
some conversation with them,
you don't have aligned
language, it's not "Star Trek."
But say you can figure that part out.
Then there's gonna be a question of like,
does the ontology that they have align
with ontology that we have at all?
Or do they have like a
totally different way
of thinking about everything?
How did that come to be?
And I think that's a, it's
an interesting question.
It's not clear, and then when you then use
that way of thinking about it
with the conversation towards
like robot scientists and AI,
like, is there any expectation
that some AI type thing,
should it be interpretable to humans?
Well, I don't know,
as long as humans are in the process
of designing experiments and
doing hypothesis generation,
it's pretty important
that we can understand
what happens for the current
experiment that we're doing.
And if we somehow seed that
and have like really black
box neural networks and things
that maybe solve the probably
we're on today, really, really well,
but if something goes wrong,
we don't know what to do next,
then the whole way in which
we aggregate knowledge
in the scientific enterprise up until then
is gonna be kind of dramatically affected.
And I think that would
probably not go well.
But I do see, and you're
already starting to see it
in like self-driving labs for
chemistry and stuff like that.
You have kind of closed loop systems,
usually only in pretty confined settings
where that's effective.
But yeah, I think it's
a fascinating question
and I don't know that I
really answered it, but.
- No, a sort of a related
a thread that occurs to me
from what you've said, Kyle,
is it domain knowledge in many ways
is traded off with the
amount of data, right?
So if you don't have domain knowledge,
I mean, is it really true
that having an infinite
amount of data means
that you don't actually
need domain knowledge?
- Oh, yeah, so that's interesting.
Well, one thing that, I mentioned earlier
this like ladder of causation.
Even if you have an
infinite amount of data
and you have like
infinite computing power,
and you can basically,
any probabilistic question
that you want to answer,
but that can be expressed
as like a joint distribution or a marginal
or something like that, you
have access to all of that.
You can do all sorts of things,
but you can only answer
questions in the lowest rung
of the causal hierarchy.
If you ever want to ask, "What
would happen if I intervene,"
you're just not gonna be able
to answer that on principle.
So, yeah, so I don't think,
that's why I don't think data,
like this whole data-driven thing--
- Yes.
- Is kind of like kind
of missing a pretty important point.
- Yeah, right, I mean, this
is where I was going, right?
Because in our fields, for example,
in astronomy, cosmology, particle physics,
I mean, we are really
hurdling towards the,
just procuring huge amounts of data,
somehow thinking that that is going
to be sort of the resolution
in providing deeper
insights into the theory,
because there are limits,
there are limits that--
- Yeah, I mean, it generally helps.
At the LHC, people use this term,
data-driven analysis techniques a lot.
What's interesting is if you look there,
a lot of times what happens is
that there's some clever
insight about like
how you can reuse the data
that has some characteristics
and then sort of use it to extrapolate
to what it would look like
in a different setting.
But the only way that
you're able to do that is
because we think, "Oh, well,
if I take out the electron
"and replace it with a muon--
- Muon.
- "And then I have this
following relationship,"
and you assume everything else
is not unchanged and all sorts of stuff.
So that looks a lot like causality.
All of those kinds of
operations are kind of
using causal structure that
physicists have learned
to do this and those are the--
(crosstalk drowns out Kyle)
- Preexisting knowledge
of causal structures, right.
- But we don't usually
describe it in those language.
We don't talk, we don't use the language
of causal inference when we do it.
- I think Sean has an urgent hand up.
There are many more
questions, but did you want to
speak up or I think you may
have to type in the chat, Sean.
Because we are in the webinar format.
- [Ty] And also, Priya,
Zenna has contributed
something in the chat.
I think because of his host privileges,
he wasn't able to go into the Q&A.
- Oh, I see.
- Do you see his question?
- I see the question, I don't know
if you see it.
- Yeah, Zenna,
go ahead and ask.
I think you can unmute yourself.
- I can maybe, well, we can just read it.
So he says, "A question, if I may.
"You mentioned that
reality seems to striated
"so that it can be understood
"at different levels of abstraction.
"Could it be instead that this is more
"about human minds than the world?
"And more pragmatically,
do you have thoughts
"of model representation
that could capture
"multiple different
abstractions simultaneously?"
Yeah, that's a great question.
Now, I mean, when you get into,
I mean, this is a super
philosophical question.
I mean, there's a like,
there's a question like to
the extent there are cells
and organs and individual, and then like
a populations of some species.
It's, to me, I guess I'm
a bit of a realist there
in that striation seems to be pretty real.
In a physics context,
you can go between things
like quarks to things like
protons and neutrons to atoms,
and it could be that
that's all an illusion.
But it's certainly, a
very effective description
has worked across wildly
different kinds of experiments.
So it's a very effective abstraction.
And again, I'm certainly
a bit of a realist there,
but like, I'm open to
the fact that it's that,
the broader philosophical
discussions there.
But in a practical sense,
whether those things
are really real or not,
the extent that humans use them as a tool
to make predictions about
things has certainly,
empirically were served as very well
in navigating the world.
And we have success after
success after success,
and using that, those
relationships to organize things.
And I think individual humans,
it certainly seems to me,
I'm not a cognitive scientist,
but that we, you read, well,
many cognitive scientists are saying is
that this does seem to be how
we're organizing the world
and that our success as
a species has a lot to do
with being able to kind of pick
the appropriate abstraction
and do reasoning very
efficiently using it.
I think then the last part
of your question to me
is the part that's the most
compelling currently is
how do we build that into some kind
of AI machine-learning-like architecture?
I think in the context of,
step one is how do you do the first,
even before different layers,
at one particular layer,
how do you include that bias?
And I think that's where you see things
like graph neural networks
for certain things
where you can really point
to individual things,
like planets and stuff like that.
It's very clear how to do
it and it works really well.
A research direction that I
think is interesting is like,
what if you didn't do that by hand?
How hard would it be to,
like if you took the data and
reorganized it in some way,
and then you said,
okay, you want some meta
machine learning algorithm to figure out,
like, what are the objects
in your ontology to attach
to nodes in a graph and
what the edges mean?
And how you would do that
in some more automated way.
That's interesting, there's
work that's going on
about dynamically building
graph neural networks,
which is in that direction.
And then there's the idea
of if you have a graph,
like coarse-graining
it so that you have a,
and that looks, it looks sort
of like the pooling operations
you see in a convolutional neural network.
So there are certainly ideas
and there are people exploring that.
And I have, trying to do some
work like that on my own.
And I think it's, that's
super, super interesting.
And there are various
people playing around
in that area right now.
- Yeah, no, I mean, Zenna
this is something we
hope to talk more about
during your presentation
on next Wednesday.
But Kyle, related to this,
I have this little aside
related, which is, I mean,
isn't it true that when we
are coarse-graining a system
in physics, for example,
it's very intentional, right?
I mean, we are coarse-graining
because we know
that at a certain level of abstraction,
we will have additional
information that we can use,
additional priors that can play into,
we know a new set of
rules, a new distribution,
a form for a distribution that will work
for the ensemble, right?
So the coarse-graining is always
because we do already have
prior information about
how a system will look when we...
- I would say yes and no.
I think that there's, I would say that,
and if you look at major
advances in science,
a lot of times it's like the fact
that you're able to first identify
here is a scale where there is an effect,
there is going to be a useful description,
and there's gonna be some kind of laws
that describe what's going on.
And then you need to kind
of have some ontology
of what are the right degrees of freedom
or the right kinds of objects
to even talk about at that scale?
And then what do their
interactions look like?
And then what are the laws
that describe that scale?
And that, sometimes that just
happens kind of on its own,
at that level.
When those things happen,
they're really important, right?
Those are like major, major
events in science, right?
- Breakthroughs, major, yeah.
- And then if you can, and in
the reductionist type picture,
if you can then tie it back
to the lower-level scale
and say like, this is how they're related,
that's even like, that's
a another, I mean,
these are all like Nobel Prize--
- Right, right.
- Type of events.
And so part of what I think is so profound
about the simulation-based
inference thing is
that you start off, it's
kind of allows you a way
to maybe bootstrap that process.
You start with a simulator at one scale,
you know what's going on.
Then there are some emergent phenomena
that are really complicated
and you don't know what they are.
But through learning, you're able to find
kind of what are the right
summaries, coarse-graining,
whatever that kind of identify
the new degrees of freedom.
You don't have a name for them yet.
But they're the new kind of
effective degrees of freedom
at that coarse-grain scale.
And then if you can just end up learning
like laws on those new
coarse-grain degrees of freedom,
then you can lift up and
operate very, very quickly,
compared to the, you know--
- Almost sounds like,
this is completely alternative.
It's not quite the demystification
of the standard process
of discovery, but almost a
brand new way for discovery.
I mean, at least it feels that way, right?
- Yeah, it just seems like
there's potentially a path
to kind of systematically hop between,
or maybe you already know the right scale
for whatever reason but you
don't know how they're related.
And you can simulate, so,
and so there are definitely,
well, we have some work going on
that's basically trying
to do exactly that.
Like, I know how to simulate it one scale.
I know there's a phenomena
emerge at a different scale,
so I can predict them.
And if it doesn't require
like exponential amount
of computing time, then
I can get enough data
where I can try to
learn that relationship.
And that's really compelling, I think.
- Thanks.
So Jeremy Zucker has the next question.
"What do you recommend as
the best Python library
"for performing
simulation-based inference?"
- Yeah, so good question.
- And something else,
"Are there some, any probabilistic
programming languages
"that can do simulation-based inference?"
- Yeah, I can give a
quick, quick guide to this
without getting too into the weeds.
So that, there's a tool called SBI,
which stands for
simulation-based inference.
It's kind of like a nice, general-purpose
Python wrapper-type of approach.
So you have a way to kind of interface
whatever simulator you have to it.
Generates data, does the
machine learning components,
and then you can do inference.
And it implements several
different techniques.
So LP is kind of, is more tied
to one specific technique.
And so, yeah, so the, which is fine,
but it's sort of less
of a toolkit in general.
And then you mentioned Etalumis.
- Etalumis, yep.
- Yeah, so that was a project
that I was involved in.
So there's a kind of
important distinction there,
which I didn't get into.
But if you remember
this diagram that I drew
that sort of had parameters on the left,
data on the right, and in the middle,
there were latent variables.
What the Etalumis and PI Prob,
this probabilistic programming approach,
it doesn't try to sort of
bypass the latent variables
and go to straight to the parameters.
It actually gives you the
capability to do inference
on the latent variables itself.
But that's a much harder problem.
It's a much more complicated
thing to try to infer.
So if you want to try to do
that, that's the tool for you.
Just know that it's a lot harder.
So in that Etalumis work,
we like use supercomputers
and stuff like that.
In other contexts, that's not required,
but kind of depends on your problem.
- Great, thank you.
So I guess is next
question is Shyam Sunder's.
"How much of this can be extended
"to study of social phenomena?"
- Yeah, it's a good question.
I mean, I think,
well, I mean,
I had this discussion
once before with like,
a lot of the way that the
simulation-based inference stuff
is set up, you need to be able
to generate data conditioned on,
or given some, I said parameter,
but it could be given
some whatever you want.
So you could, for instance,
look at the text of tweets
given a certain hashtag.
And that could be like a political hashtag
or it could be the use of
some emoji or something
like your favorite sports team
or something like that, right?
So it doesn't actually
have to be a simulator.
You just need a data-generating process
that you can condition on.
And so that makes it interesting
because you have the opportunity
to realize what I was talking about
when you have real world
data generation process.
So also, like for instance,
I showed this toy.
I can just generate
data from this toy over
and over and over, it doesn't
have to be a simulator.
I can use the actual physical
system to generate the data
and use all the same
methodology that I described.
So I think there's a, there's
an opportunity to use that
in all sorts of different
like social contexts
and things like that.
Obviously, if you're
gonna go down that road,
you should take a moment
to think about the ethics
of what you're doing
and all of the things.
Those are important considerations.
But in terms of the methodology itself,
there's certainly opportunities.
- Great, thank you very much.
So the next question is
from Michael Churchill.
"For simulation-based inference,
"what are the prospects for working
"with very, very expensive simulators,
"like exascale computing?"
- Yeah, so that's a good,
also a really good question.
So in the context of
Large Hadron Collider,
the real collisions are happening
about 40 million times a second,
but to simulate one collision
takes about 10 minutes.
So there's like an enormous
gap between how long, but
10 minutes doesn't sound
that bad and you can run it
on a fairly normal computer
and we have a lot of computers.
So it's expensive, but it's doable.
If you wanted to go into a
situation like, for instance,
you look at the waveforms
that come inside of the LIGO,
the gravitational-wave detector,
then you wanna predict what
those waveforms look like,
given some black hole merger,
that simulation, at one point,
requires numerical relativity
and all sorts of stuff.
Or then there's other phases
where you can do that faster,
but it's still pretty expensive.
And that's to simulate the
waveform for like one scenario.
And now you wanna scan through this
fairly high-dimensional space
that describes the different
ways the black holes
might be oriented and their mass
and spin and all these things.
So that becomes expensive.
And, but actually, if you
wanted to try to do normal,
like Bayesian inference in that setting,
it's really, really, really expensive.
So people have started using
likelihood-free inference techniques
or simulation-based inference techniques
basically to make that faster.
And so what's nice is that
you now have situations,
you pay an upfront training cost,
but once you're done with that, you have
what's called an amortized setup
where you can do inference very quickly.
So now there's systems where they can look
at the waveforms and within microseconds,
tell you what the posterior
distribution on the sky is
so that you can slew your telescopes.
But there's definitely a lot
of ongoing work about how to--
- But that, but Kyle, in that case,
the training set is
finite and limited, right?
So there's a limited set of waveforms
that are real gravitational waves, right?
Or you think that when you say,
when you refer to the training set,
do you mean like the full set
of all possible wave patterns?
- Or like the ones that you,
the ones that you would get
from like say running a simulation--
- A GR simulation, yeah, GR.
- With whatever approximations or things
you wanna stick in your simulator.
I don't wanna get into the weeds
of like post Newtonian stuff.
But the, what was I gonna say?
Sorry, the, oh, the other thing there is
that there's a lot of work going on,
which is, at the beginning,
say, like for that example,
you don't know where on
the sky and you don't know,
have any idea what the
mass of black holes were.
But you could make a
very rough scan at first
and start to get an idea and then refine
with more simulations
in the relevant region.
And so you have this kind
of iterative approach
that uses this buzzword of
kind of active learning.
And so there are techniques
that do simulation-based inference
where there's like an active learning loop
on the top to try to make the simulation
as efficient as possible.
- Because, I mean, these
are cases where doing,
having a library would be too onerous,
would be too computationally
expensive, right?
- Yeah, trying to do it upfront
is like, yeah, not great.
And earlier there's a
question about software.
This SBI tool, for instance,
implements these
active-learning techniques,
but there's some others as well, yeah.
There's one called Swift,
which is pretty nice.
- Let me see if there are,
I think there's one more question.
It's Jeremy Zucker again,
"If your simulator is differentiable,
"what methods exist to speed
up simulation-based inference?"
- Yeah, that's a great question.
So I mean, without trying
to give a shameless plug
or something, we wrote a review article
about simulation-based inference
techniques, which maybe--
- It's a great article,
by the way, I can plug it.
It was in PNAS and I
think it got me started
thinking about these issues.
- Yeah, but it was meant
to be fairly accessible.
One of the things that we spent
some time there is saying,
if you can open up your
simulator, open up the black box
and either instrument it with
probabilistic programming
type of skills, or if it's differentiable,
there's different ways
it can be differentiable.
It can be differentiable in the sense
of like input-output relationships,
or it can be differentiable in the sense
of the probability of
this run of the simulator,
Like what's the derivative
of that probability
with respect to the
parameters of the simulator?
So there are different
kinds of derivatives
that you can take.
You can take advantage of them
and it can lead to dramatically
more efficient learning.
So we have a paper called "Mining Gold"
which talks about one type of derivative.
And there, we show that
for several problems
that we were looking at,
we could reduce the simulation budget
by like three orders of magnitude.
So if you can take those derivatives,
things that were taking millions,
tens of millions of simulations
turned into like 1,000.
So that's a pretty big difference.
- Great, thanks very much.
Are there any other questions?
I'll just give everyone another minute
if they want to type
something up or type up.
If not, I mean, to be continued.
I really look forward to the conversation
between you and Zenna next Wednesday.
Meanwhile, thanks Kyle
for this wonderful talk,
really clear talk,
explaining simulation-based
inference to us
and looking forward to
seeing you on Wednesday.
Thanks everyone--
- Thank you very much.
- Yeah, thanks everyone,
I also want to say,
give a big thanks to
Ty and to Guy Ortoleva
for helping with the logistics
and organizing this talk and series.
Bye everyone, and see you next Wednesday.